hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested and not this
game in particular but you said you guys
would enjoy seeing at least one game
from netflix new series uh the queen's
gambit
and uh i'm not gonna throw around any
spoilers if you guys
still haven't seen it so if you want to
check out the series first and then
watch this video then just end it now
uh it's uh very short it's only seven
episodes so it will take you some eight
hours to watch it uh so
like if you have eight hours free maybe
today or or some other day
uh you can watch in one day but you
could also like me watch it
uh through the course of uh i think
we've seen it
you know within within some four days uh
but
uh regardless it's uh you know it's
really great uh i've seen i've seen much
worse uh movies um
uh made uh you know uh based on chess
uh so this is uh this is really a great
great series so i'm sure you're gonna
enjoy it and
this is uh again spoiler alert if any of
you want to watch it and
ended the video now and only come back
to it after you've seen the series
uh but this is the final game of the
series where uh our main protagonist
elizabeth harmon played by
anya taylor joy uh takes on the world
champion in this case vasily borgov
and it's quite the game it's quite the
game and it's based on an
actual game we're gonna talk about that
after uh we check out the game or and
at least until we reach the position uh
where the game shifts and
takes uh takes a different turn so
without further ado
let's check it out it's quite a beauty
of the game uh
the actual game is quite a beauty the
game that
they made for the show that was based on
the actual game is
well even greater but it was made uh
with the help of some incredibly strong
grand masters and i imagine a very very
strong chess engines
so without further ado let's check it
out elizabeth harman with the white
pieces
opens with d4 and it's very interesting
uh
the show is called the queen's gambit so
we might expect a d4 on the board
uh but uh throughout her entire life she
was an e4 player
and only when now when facing the world
champion she employs a d4
and now is that someone does that remind
you of someone else we know from from
that
particular era uh but okay uh we have d5
by borgo
c4 uh the queen's gambit is on the board
and d captures on c4 so accepting the
queen's gambit we have e4
uh and knight to c6 now with a double
attack on the d4 pawn bishop to e3
defending and now
knight to f6 we have knight to c3
defending the four pawn as it was
attacked and now e5 uh sorry
e5 by black uh white replies with d5
grabbing more space in the center and
the knight to e7 the knight can come to
g6 in the future uh and and find some
use there we have bishop captures on c4
uh recapturing the the so uh gambited
pawn and
knight to g6 now uh and now f3 just
setting up a very strong center here
uh while white continues development
with bishop to d6 and the queen to d2
now
bishop to d7 both players just continue
developing and
knight g to e2 we have a6 preparing b5
and
some queen side expansion and bishop to
b3
in anticipation of this we have b5 and
now
uh uh elizabeth decides to to attack the
flank here
with a4 uh both players castle
we have castles castles and now comes
queen to e7 so just continuing
development
and rook a to c1 putting pressure on the
c file black still has a backwards c7
pawn
so we might be able to do something
about that and here knight to h5
saying that okay the f4 square is is a
square
i'm going to use for my knights i'm
going to play f5 maybe bust open the
position maybe
play a four uh we'll we'll see how it
goes as uh white only has a light square
bishop and with
the pawns set on light squares here it's
not going to be
not going to be a very very useful piece
so here g3
taking away the f4 square from the
knights and now
uh h6 uh just improving the position a
little bit before continuing the attack
bishop to c2 and now comes rook a to b8
now with ideas of uh
pushing the pawn you could also maybe
capture uh you could go bishop to b4 and
then capture so
a lot of ideas here so white captures on
b5 instead
a captures on b5 and now sda file opened
up rook to a1 with ideas of shifting the
rook over to a7
and uh you know finding some rook uh
finding some use on the seventh rank
uh rook to a8 borgo of course does not
allow that and now
bishop to d3 with a double attack on the
b5 pawn
bishop to b4 pinning the knight so now
the pawn cannot be captured and
rook captures an a8 we have one rook
trait on the a file captures captures
and queen to c2 now unpinning and once
again introducing the threat of picking
up the b5 pawn
so bishop back to c5 now saying okay
your bishop is
unguarded here uh you still cannot
capture the b5 pawn you have to deal
with this
and here elizabeth defends with knight
to d1 now it's a very
uh very uh interesting idea uh so what
uh
what can be done here the b5 pawn is no
longer under attack however
your bishop on e3 is defended and if you
trade here then the knight gets
to the e3 squared then the knight can
come to f5 and so on
so here bishop back to d6 by borgov now
just again defending his backwards c7
pawn
and knight to f2 improving the position
of the knights and here we have
a beautiful move by borgov knight h to
f4 so it's
just just an amazing move uh the knight
can be captured by the pawn by the
bishop by the night
also bonus question for for you great
great uh
knowledgeable chess fans uh what other
game features a spectacular knight to f4
move
uh that could be captured in in a lot of
ways
uh so that's also played in russia so
that's uh that's a good question for you
uh but
uh that out of the way uh not capturing
the knight as that would be a completely
different game where
white would have to settle for uh
defending the the position
being attacked for example captures
captures the bishop is attacked bishop
c1 knight h4
black still having the bishop paired the
rook can can join
uh the attack the queen can come into
the attack so it would be
it will be again game where white has to
defend so instead after this knight
uh h2 f4 we have rook to c1 uh in the
series elizabeth is not portrayed as
someone who plays boring chess who likes
the trait who likes to go uh for the end
game
uh she's portrayed as someone who who
plays
spectacular chess makes flashy
sacrifices ends the game very quickly
whereas uh vasily borgo the russian the
world champion of course is known
as the i i believe as the best player
end game player in the world so of
course she wants to avoid that at any
cost
so uh queen to g5 now uh adding the
queen to the attack and immediately with
a threat
uh you you you have to be very careful
for example if the knight moves
somewhere uh with check you might lose
the bishop on e3
not something you want to do then you'll
be stuck with a light square bishop and
your light squares aren't really uh
aren't really made for your light square
bishop at the moment so here king to h1
not allowing any checks and now queen to
h5
again allowing this knight to be
captured but uh
capturing the knight is just terrible
queen captures on f3 with
check and believe it or not you're
getting checkmated king the g1 knight h4
threatening checkmate and there's not
much you can do king f1 queen g2 check
you're gonna go king e1
knights the f3 check also taking the d1
square from your
from your king king to d1 and queen to
f1 is now checkmate unbelievable
uh but it it is possible here i mean
there are so many pieces here look at
this
and the queen and i deliver checkmate so
this is what happens if the knight is
captured so instead
knight to g1 uh end
and now comes knight captures on d3 so
grabbing that bishop
uh we have knight captures back on d3
and only now
f5 borgov continues the onslaught here
on the king side
we have knight to c5 going after the
light square bishop and just the khan
bishop the c8
taking care of everything nicely
controlling the knight here
rook to f1 if the f file opens up you do
want to have your rook there
and now knight to e7
uh so what do you do here uh queen to d3
again uh putting pressure uh on on the
pawn here and now comes
f captures an e for not allowing uh
white amounts rest f captures and now
queen to g6 again asking white what do
you want to do here
and uh well it's never possible to
capture the b5 pawn for example if you
capture it then black just removes the
defender of the e4 pawn
and after let's say bishop captures just
queen captures an e4 getting rid of an
extremely important pawn and black would
would be very much winning here so
instead after queen to g6 we have king
to g2
uh improving the position of the king
preparing knight to f3
and king to h7 now black does the same
we have knight to f3
and now comes knight to g8 now the
knight is coming into the attack
knight the h4 putting pressure on the
queen and queen to g4
and now finally grabbing hold of that f5
square making the bishop looking
uh a little bit weird here as he's not
doing all that much and you you never
really
want to give it up for for this knight
here uh however we have
knight to f6 and now comes h3 and here
we reach a very interesting position uh
because
uh without playing h3 you just run into
captures and then you lose the four pawn
and then
the entire gate game uh
is lost the position just crumbles
however after
h3 uh such things are not possible the
queen has to move
and interestingly in the series uh in
this final game
uh borgo uh uh adjourns the game he says
uh
he he wants to join the game he puts the
move in
in the little uh envelope the arbiter
takes it and the game will be continued
tomorrow tomorrow and for those of you
who are just joining in the chess world
who are not
uh well uh who maybe don't know what an
adjournment is
when a pl when a game is adjourned it
means that okay
we we've played it enough today we're
going to continue it tomorrow
and then we're just going to continue
from the same position such a thing is
not possible today because you would
just allow the engine to to crunch the
game and you would have all the answers
in the morning so
it would basically be a matter of
preparation
uh which is similar but uh when in those
days when you analyzed the game yourself
uh
throughout the course of the entire
night or for example if you were a world
champion and you had a
an entire team of seconds who would
analyze for you and just uh
gave you the answers in the morning it
would be much better of course because
you would be
much more well arrested for for the for
the next day
however i'm not gonna spoil too much
what happens here basically the game is
adjourned and continue tomorrow so here
tomorrow after this h3 move
uh borgov plays queen to g6 and here
we reach the position so up until this
point this was an
actual game believe it or not such a
such a crazy fighting game
i'm i'm only sorry that we we've uh
never shown
the game uh as it actually was
it's actually a game played by none
other than uh vasily even chook with the
white pieces against patrick wolf
from the 1993 uh beale chess festival i
don't know if it was called chess
festival there but it was played in
beale
and the game ended in a draw uh uh
vasily played the g4 here and it was a
brutal brutal fighting game us
lasted a lot of moves but in the end
ended in the draw we might show the
actual game as well at some point
however here as this netflix series uh
elizabeth harmon finds an
improvement on unchalky's move and she
plays knight
to e6 and here our game really starts
because up until this point it was all
an actual game that was actually played
in 1993 but here
uh we finally enter the the fiction
uh you know uh area of the game
so here while you could capture the
knight it doesn't really offer you all
that much you just give wider past pawn
and now whether this is good whether you
can defend this where you want to defend
this guy or you want to stop the past
pawn it could go
could go different ways but it doesn't
really matter because the borgov here
plays the absolute best move and that is
rook to a4
he goes after the e4 pawn and now well
we already mentioned that the e4 pawn is
basically the thing holding white's
entire position together
so it would be it would be very
unrealistic to give it up but it is
tempting to give it up what about the g7
pawn can we just capture the g7 pawn
what happens if we do
well it's uh it's one thing that we have
to consider for example 90 captures on
g7
and now we give up the e4 pawn and now
the knight just retreats and here we
have a completely crazy position where
black has
knight captures on g3 now you cannot
capture with the king or the knight
because the king
will cannot capture and if the knight
captures the queen hangs on d3
however there is the incredible knight
to e7
uh white sacrifices the queen and now
you can either capture the queen
and go into what uh white wants or you
could just capture the knight and say
okay i'm not interested in your
silliness so let's see what happens if
you capture the knight
if you capture the knight you get rook
to f7 check the black queen is pinned so
you cannot capture this
king the g8 and now queen captures on g6
with check king to h8 and now rook
captures or
queen to g7 or h7 is checkmate not
captures without captures
uh but it is checkmate and after this
knight to e7 move if you actually accept
the queen sacrifice
uh then it's rooked f7 check and we
have a draw by repetition king h8 rook
f8 check king h7 rook to f7
check and so on so uh after rook to a4
this is
actually uh accepting a draw so here
elizabeth goes for b3 and it's such a
such a wonderful move again allows uh
black so many options
do you go for rook to eight you do go
for rook captures on e4 do you go for
knight captures on e4
so we're just going to briefly uh check
out what happens for example after rook
to
rook day to check white can block and
here let's say we trade rooks characters
captures
uh we get this position where the e4
pawn is nicely defended
and the g7 pawn still hangs so could be
good
maybe you can sorry maybe you can take
take one of the knights and
just continue the game in that way
however it's again
incredibly interesting what happens if
knight captures on e4
then you sacrifice the rook b captures
on a4
knight captures on g3 sorry the wrong
knight
again with the same idea if knight
captures you hang the queen
but again we have knight to e7 now just
if captured then you can capture the
queen and pick up the knight so
there's that but also if the queen is
accepted then we have
another draw by repetition knight to f8
to check taking away all of these
squares uh
from the from the black king and here we
would just have another draw by
repetition king h8 knight
checks king h7 knight checks and so on
another draw by repetition
so here after b3 uh we have the third
move that we still haven't checked so
not
this not the disc but rather rook
captures an e4 which was played
in the actual series uh and here we have
to uh
ask ourselves what happens next so here
uh
knight captures on d6 is the move so
knight captures on d6 removing the
defender of the f8 square and now knight
to f8
check is a huge problem for black so of
course you cannot play cd
as then just uh check and you lose the
queen so bishop captures an e6 is a must
which allows uh elizabeth to create a
beautiful pass pawn here
and now c captures on d6 which gives
borgo
an incredibly strong center if this pawn
starts rolling down the board
it's going to be very difficult so here
elizabeth pushes e7 the d8 square is
nicely protected however that can change
very very easily and here we have
another beautiful moment in the game and
in the series d5
is played and d5 is a problem because
when they adjourned the game yesterday
and
uh well not again not trying to spoil
anything but
the game was analyzed and a lot of
continuations were considered uh
so uh d5 was not amongst the
continuations that were considered and
this
uh this was a problem for elizabeth
because
she now start had to start thinking up
until this point i believe she had
everything
analyzed at home for the game so uh
the thing is uh she starts staring at
the ceiling
and this is this was just an incredible
moment for me because it's a game
uh by none other than the great vasily
vancouver from the 1993 build tournament
and
who stares at the ceiling more than
vasily manchuk
now when elizabeth stares at the ceiling
in the series
it's uh it's for a good reason but you
know
when when uh even chook stairs at the
ceiling i'm sure it's also for for a
very good reason
so here d5 was played and it's actually
it's actually a pretty
pretty strong move uh because uh well
the the rook is nicely defended here for
example if you don't play
such a movie if you play something like
b4 let's just say you make a move
you you ruin the game immediately
because just rook captures on f6
and we already said you have to remove
the defenders of the e8 square so here g
capture so the queen would still keep on
defending it but just e8 queen
and that's it you have to capture the
queen and the rook is now eliminated and
black does have two extra pawns but
it's not going to help all that much
against the bishop so here after e7 d5
uh fixes that issue because now after
rook caltrans just g captures there's
there's no this the rook is nicely
defended
so instead after d5 we have this
beautiful
bishop to c5 move defending the past
pawn and preparing to cement the
position with b4 and
black doesn't really have all that many
options uh because
well you like we said you have to keep
an eye on this square
uh if you move the rook white can for
example just trade queens and then pick
up
pick off the knight promote the the pawn
to a queen
even if you trade queens and go knight
back the rook can still come to f8 and
harass the knight so it's uh it's a very
passive position for black to play so
here we have queen back to e8
guarding the b5 pawn while also hanging
on to the to the queening square and
white doesn't seem to have all that much
to do
queen to f3 now with some ideas of queen
to f5
check although it doesn't really promise
all that much
and queen to c6 by borgov uh we have b4
defending the bishop and now this is a
beautiful setup here
nicely controlling the rook here uh not
not much for black to do
and here you have to play king to g8
king to g8 is the only good move for
black here just a waiting
move waiting to see what white will
white will play however
borgov uh makes his well first
big mistake of the game he plays queen
back to e8
thinking probably i don't know if he was
thinking that because it's
show that he might be able to repeat
moves maybe with queen to c6 queen to e8
uh however this completely blunders the
game uh
here uh he actually offered her a draw
which means that if she accepts uh then
it's a it's a tie
between her and the world champion on
this tournament in those days if you
remember they had
shared firsts which is now again being
introduced in online chess
uh something that i thought was very
weird uh but okay
uh here he offers a draw and she
declines the draw she says nope we play
on and she plays
queen to f5 with check and now it's uh
well it's a very a very tough decision
because if you go king to g8
uh which is uh possible then you get
queen the e6
check king has to go back and now you
just give up the rook captures captures
next move it's queen to f8 and
the pawn gets promoted this one check
doesn't do all that much of the king can
just attack the rook you waste the move
and again queen to f8
is coming so uh king the g8 is out of
out of question so king the 88 is what
borgov plays
but now feel free to pause the video and
win this game for elizabeth
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting a
beautiful beautiful queen sacrifice
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's queen captures on f6
uh you know when was another uh
beautiful game played where the queen
was sacrificed on f6
uh that's also a question so g captures
on f6
and now rook captures on f6 so now
elizabeth is down a queen but
rook to f8 check is coming and there's
not much uh black can do about it
we have queen to h5 trying to go for
some sort of a mating attack if maybe
you can start
checking the white king maybe good
things will happen however
uh rook to f8 with check and this is the
only good move you have to uh
move with great haste so you also have
to
defend the queening square rook to f8 to
check king to g7 and now just
e8 queen bringing another queen into the
game and now white is up a full bishop
and what an important bishop it is
because he can always retreat to df2
square guarding against
any any and all checks so here while
black can
capture and maybe trust his uh two two
pass pawns will
be enough to handle the bishop it's
definitely not enough and the white has
all the compensation in the world
so here we have rook to e2 with check uh
and
now comes uh although uh here at this
point they didn't show
in in the series what was actually
played so i had to reconstruct
the game uh until they've they've shown
the position that
that was possible so this is what i
think that actually happened in in
in the series uh rook to e2 check king
to f1
now attacking the rook and now queen to
h3 with
check because black has to move with
with tempo otherwise he's just getting
checkmated
so here a nice rook sacrifice and queen
to g2 hoping to get some sort of a
perpetual with queen to e4 but uh white
shows that that's not happening
rook to f2 we have queen to e4 check now
hoping for king to f1 followed by queen
to h1 again going for some sort of a
perpetual
but here elizabeth just picks up the
king and
very very slowly drags it all the way to
d2
and uh well it was uh it was in this
position that vasily borgo
the world chess champion uh resigned the
game
and uh not not only did he resign he
also
stood up and gave her a standing ovation
uh
like like some other a great russian
world champion we know
uh that uh you know certain game sex so
a lot of uh
a lot of similarities here uh in the
show uh and he was also
very nice like like the person i'm
talking about but again
i don't want to spell too much because
here you resign there's nothing much to
do
i mean uh rook f7 is coming bishop to f8
is coming there's nothing to do here
uh and there are no more checks the the
bishop covers everything there's no
check here
there's no check here there's no check
here the pawn and rook cover that so
there are no checks
and whatever you're playing doesn't
really matter you're just getting
checkmated bishop fa to check
there's nowhere to go all of this these
squares are covered
let's say queen fa to check and now
anything just delivers mate queen g7
uh so of course after king to d2 borgo
resigned and
elizabeth wins the tournament uh which
was
which was really incredible as you know
there were some incredibly strong
players
there uh but yeah uh just so uh i don't
forget
a big shout out to olympia and the chess
historian who cracked which game this
was that they were playing
i was planning on uh you know running
all the moves through
some databases that until i finally uh
pick up on the games that were
added that were actually used in the
show uh but he already did this on
twitter so
a big shout out to him there you can see
beth harmon's final game with vasily
borgov
her russian nemesis is based on that
spectacular draw between evancho
uh and wolf from the 1993 bill
interzonal ah so it's a bill interzonal
uh now we know that as well and there
you have it uh
in the series the the moment where she
puts pushes h3 and he requests the
adjournment of the game
uh but yeah uh that's uh the game uh i
do hope you enjoyed it
the real game is incredible the
deconstructed game for the series is
just out of this world but they had a
lot of help
uh you know in the series for for
choosing games uh
by some some great great names like uh
like
gary kasparov uh bruce pandolfini was
also a member of
of the team and probably some others
that i don't know of but
i'm gonna uh study into it a bit more so
if you guys are interested in stuff like
this we can also make like uh like a
complete
overview of the series and you know
what's real what's not what was possible
what was not and
something like that i don't know if you
guys would be interested in that
but yeah that's the game i do hope you
enjoyed it both the real one and the
constructed one
uh i would like to thank hs app uh
sergey maximo vladimir pereich
david traynor and james eugene for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do check
out the series it's it's quite nice see
you soon guys